[Music]
we have such a good show tonight I love
that hat look at this hat this
gentleman's wearing right here that is a
cool hat may I borrow that I'd like to
wear your hat just for a second just
right here look at this hat I can't pull
these off people say
[Applause]
my head is so huge yeah it's like a
hipster yarmulke I mean it's very nice
there you go sir thank you very much
letting me borrow that Boyle that hat
you don't know what's in there
I'm liking tonight's show what did he do
he smelled it
you smelled it there's a reason it
smells like salad dressing what are you
into
I'm never gonna wash this Lindsay Lohan
is in trouble again ladies and gentlemen
do you hear this Lindsay Lohan was
arrested in New York City last night for
allegedly hitting someone with her car
and leaving the scene of an accident
yeah that is the bad news the good news
is she's not driving in Los Angeles we
can cross this Jeana just gonna go back
and forth in the crosswalk it is true
though Lindsay Lohan did flee the scene
after a car accident yeah low and
apologize saying she was late for a car
accident across town she's very Hourigan
huh yeah yeah she's cut them planned out
did you know what a weird thing it
happened on the Disney Channel the
Disney Channel accidentally aired
several minutes of hardcore porn during
one of their children's cartoons
that's true that's right
either that or a Phineas and Ferb really
like each other big with my kids you
excited about the new iPhone 5 Apple bad
news Apple has pushed back the shipping
date for the new iPhone 5 they pushed it
back they say don't worry though it
should be delivered the day before they
unveil the iPhone 6
I think that's actually just a true
thing that I say is yeah that's not so
much a joke they are going to do that
all right
here's a new one with a different
connecting port this is me paying that's
what I'm doing
I'm the mime who explains what he's
doing
ladies and gentlemen an asian
mathematician appears to have solved the
world's most complex math problem he did
so as part of his work at the Institute
for persistent stereotypes
[Applause]
you heard they found this document that
seems to validate that Jesus had
alighted here with her yeah his wife
yeah scholars have uncovered an ancient
document that talks about Jesus having a
wife yeah
they also found a note from Jesus's
father-in-law it's saying tell that bum
to cut his hair and get a job Jesus was
just hanging around a lot just hanging
around the apartment no I think I'll go
down to the river and preach thrombo
let's go all right at the big news at
the International Space Station an
American astronaut just completed an
entire triathlon in space in space yeah
in a in a in a related story I finally
took the laundry off the treadmill in my
garage
[Applause]
[Music]
it's too hard and I stopped McDonald's
announced there will be a delay in the
return of the McRib this year yeah
spokesman said we're waiting for people
to finish digesting last year's McCray
[Applause]